joining us on the line is james o'keefe
founder and president of project veritas
on tuesday morning he live-streamed the
president of cnn
jeff zucker's 9am editorial call and he
says that he has been recording
for months these cnn internal calls and
they're going to start releasing clips
from the calls today at 7 00 p.m
well james thanks for joining the show
hey thanks ben
thanks for having me on so first of all
i'm not going to ask how you got access
to the cause i assume you have somebody
inside the
inside the game over at cnn obviously
jeff zucker seemed somewhat taken aback
when you started talking to him on the
conference call
and now cnn is threatening legal action
against you what do you make of that
well i mean the legal action i mean it's
ridiculous and uh i think jeff's just
mad and embarrassed
uh you know to be threatening me with
arrest for reporting on the phone call
but yeah ben we have
insider sources inside the organization
and that's what it's the paragon of
investigative reporting to have that
sort of thing so it's really ironic for
cnn to be threatening me
but definitely jeff was shocked to hear
me tell him that we've been recording
the calls for two months
and uh we've been we've been just
releasing those clips last night we're
going to continue to release them day by
day so let's go through some of the
clips that you've been releasing
uh what were the clips that you released
last night for people who missed it
so there was a clip of um of a couple
different with there was
jeff zucker himself talking about the
need to not normalize the president
to sort of lean into certain things and
not cover others
uh there's a clip where they're talking
about how the 911
the transition and they're sort of
saying the transition is going to affect
national security
uh they're talking about tucker carlson
being a white supremacist that's the
general counsel of
cnn saying that fox news is the white
supremacist hour
and generally there's this ethos of of
jeff sucker the president of cnn
which is unusual for a media ceo a media
conglomerate ceo to be directing the
narrative to be
telling his reporters what to cover and
what not to cover and as
the president of my own organization
featuring journalists
they kind of tell me what the story is i
don't really direct them in that
particular way so you sort of see how
the sausage is made
on these first few clips there at cnn
yeah it is pretty incredible that cnn is
still considered an objective news
source by so many people when it is very
obvious that the editorial take is being
driven by by the top i mean there been
rumors that jeff zucker is on his way
out do you think this is going to
contribute
in any way to uh jeff sucker retiring
from cnn giving it was pretty
humiliating
i do i i i say that because of the
reactions from cnn
they have been i've been doing cnn
exposes for years
and this is the first time they've
really reacted to it i mean cnn
corporate communications has put out a
couple statements and he actually on the
if you watch the video of me live
streaming
they were so taken aback uh and it's
sort of like the psychological aspect
too
now i i believe that they should be
transparent i don't think they should be
ashamed of anything they're saying right
there
on those calls um but i think that
they're shaking in their boots
and just the fact that we have you know
hundreds of
hours of recordings and we're going to
release them a little bit at a time i
akin to a december advent calendar day
by day
i think that's just psychologically
traumatizing to jeff sucker so
i'm not asking for you to uh sort of
blow up your release schedule but what
is the
kind of general tenor of some of the
material that you're looking to release
in upcoming days
you know there's something coming out
today about like hunter biden and
zuckers talking about that and and what
to cover what not to cover
um i i think a lot of this stuff ben is
not gonna
i don't know if it'll shock people
because the chirons on cnn are already
so shocking i don't think people are
gonna go whoa
but i do think it it gives an insight
it kind of confirms suspicions about how
the sausage is made how
how the organization manufactures
consent to quote noam chomsky how they
how they how they kind of tell people
what the narrative is and what the story
is and that's not
journalism in my opinion so i think it's
important work and i hopefully
hopefully it draws out more
whistleblowers inside these
companies to come out like the person
who came to me inside cnn so you've had
a wide variety of whistleblowers at a
wide variety of these media companies
uh and uh has there been more of an
increase in that given the fact that
these companies have become so overtly
political as
in recent years i mean they're always
political but they used to at least try
to hide it
yeah the whistleblowers is now our new
bread and butter at veritas we used to
we we still do undercover work but
undercover works about access so people
have to be incredibly brave
almost self-sacrificial to do this they
have to basically jump on a grenade in
most cases
we saw with the postal workers with the
election and you know the ballots
but google facebook twitter cnn new york
times
there are people inside these
institutions that are so uh
you know betrayed by by what the oath
they thought they were taking when they
joined those networks and there are even
a few people reached out to me off the
record
to tell me that and to and to kind of
praise what we're doing
but it's like the you know the soviet
union they can't they can't
ever ever say that to anyone or even
publicly
james o'keefe founder and president of
project veritas obviously every time you
drop a tape
the media immediately respond by
suggesting that you are selectively
editing
and that you're a con artist this goes
all the way back to acorn
uh back into our salad days when we were
both working with andrew breitbart
uh so how do you respond to the
allegations that all of this is
basically just you taking things out of
context and manufacturing narratives
well i would say you know name the edit
ben you know when you and i worked
together 11 years ago
you know jerry brown was attacking me
because the acorn people didn't break
the law but that's
not that then they then they do to
non-sequitur and say well i edited the
tapes well name the specific edit name
the specific thing
that we got wrong now i will say i did
have to publish a correction a very rare
correction in this story
because i couldn't i couldn't figure out
the name of the people speaking
the person that did in fact brand uh
tucker carlson as a white supremacist
was cnn's general counsel i
i had mislabeled him because i couldn't
i couldn't identify him
but that even makes it worse that the
general counsel of the organization is
saying that
but no we have they can never actually
name and edit all journalism is edited
selectively so words are arranged into
sentences
and articles on newsprint but video
transfixes in a way that words do not
and i think
and i think in this climate you we have
to have video uh
to to make our to illustrate our point
otherwise they're just gonna call us
liars if we
if we use hearsay or or secondhand
sources so jim what do you think is the
proper response of conservatives to the
confirmation obviously the overwhelming
bias not only in the media but also of
social media you've had whistleblowers
from various social media companies
uh it has now become perfectly obvious
that social media companies are
militarizing on behalf of democratic
narratives as they did
in the hunter biden story to literally
shut that thing down two weeks out from
the election president trump over the
past 48 hours
has suggested that he might actually
veto a defense authorization bill unless
there is some sort of massive change to
section 230.
what do you think would be a good
solution to the overwhelming tsunami
of propaganda put forth by one side of
the political aisle here
well i'm i'm very i'm very biased
towards towards my own mission here but
generally i would say
expose them you know you have to what
what they fear more than anything else
is being exposed they're masters of
psychological projection they accuse
other people of doing the very things
that they do
the new york times did that to me when
they after they attacked me after the
minnesota story
saying i use anonymous sources that's
rich we always
show people's lips moving and you can
hear their voices but ben we need to
expose them
we need to and i think there's a
psychological issue where a lot of
some people even in the conservative
movement uh you know they they drink
from that poison chalice they want to be
liked by the new york times they don't
want to be hated and by the way being
hated by these people
is not easy being viciously and savagely
defamed and attacked
constantly is not an easy thing to
endure and you don't
escape unscathed so i think there's
almost like a psychological thing that
conservatives have to do
where they're not afraid to be defamed
and attacked
unfairly by these organizations and
that's what you have to endure
if you want to accomplish the mission
the stated mission
of revealing their bias their
malfeasance
their manufacturing consent you have to
be willing to be
viciously attacked not fun but uh i
think a worthwhile cause
james o'keefe founder and president of
project veritas if you want to help them
out head on over to project veritas
online they do accepted donations as far
as i'm more james really appreciate the
time and uh thanks for the insight
thanks ben
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content